[Music]
in south africa there's something called
the taxi mafia the taxi mafia is
stronger and more feared than most of
the south african police force and the
military it often has more influence on
the country than the actual government
and they are ruthless and won't hesitate
to kill now before you start imagining
guys with greasy hair sitting in a
yellow sedan the taxis in south africa
look nothing like what you see in the us
or europe they're basically 16 seater
toyota quantums that are always always
carrying more than 16 people
16 25
34
35 there are more than 200 000 taxis in
south africa but they only follow a
select number of specific routes in and
around cities 200 000 taxis all
competing for the same routes that's why
the actual taxi drivers only make around
150 dollars a month even though the
industry itself is worth 1.2 billion
dollars and carries 15 million
passengers every day so drivers feel
like they have no choice but to join a
union a taxi association that supposedly
protects their job except in reality the
taxi union bosses and the owners of
these taxis the workers are driving are
the ones pocketing most of the cash so
combine the extreme poverty with a
limited number of taxi routes the
constant fear of being shot or attacked
tough competition for passengers weapons
and ample supply a very sensitive ratio
and political climate along with
powerful taxi union bosses that need to
protect their cash flow and therefore
their taxi routes and you have the
perfect climate for widespread organized
violence and turf wars where taxi unions
fight over everything from routes to
prices to the skin color of their
members that's why in south africa taxis
are symbolic of two things bad driving
and violence
where the best way to compete for
passengers is to hire a hitman to shoot
at rival taxis
over the last 20 years half of all the
assassinations in south africa were
related to taxi mafias in an industry
that transports more than 60 of south
africa's daily commuters getting caught
in the middle of a taxi war can mean
death these taxi unions don't just stop
at shooting up their competitors vans
they resort to all-out mafia tactics
intimidating passengers burning vehicles
hiring hitmen to take out the boss of an
opposing gang and the government they
won't lift a finger because everyone
knows not even a politician is too
powerful for the taxi mafias to reach
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one of the perks of being a taxi mafia
boss is that you get to feast like a
modern day king but just because you can
feast like a modern day king doesn't
mean you should do so in an unhealthy
manner that's where magic spoon comes in
today's video is sponsored you guys know
magic spoon right now the insanely
healthy cereal that maintains that
healthiness while still tasting just as
good as the sugary delicious cereal you
had as a kid a cereal that you guys have
been loving and today ironically i don't
have a bowl at this place so we're gonna
use this cup so today we have blueberry
and magic spoon now has 13 to 14 grams
of protein per serving three to four net
grams of carbs and zero grams of sugar
my favorite flavors are cocoa chocolate
fruity loose fruit and cinnamon and
lucky for you guys you can build a
variety pack with the link below where
you can put together all these flavors
and more so support them and support
your own health by heading to the link
below
magicspoon.com to grab a variety pack
right now and be sure to use the coupon
code j tran ad checkout for five dollars
off your order now in the us and canada
[Music]
magic spoon is so confident in the
product that is backed by a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for whatever reason they
will give you your money back that's
magicspoon.com jake tran with the link
below and back to the video
because also i believe that it is
according to god's will
that the white race which is in the
majority in this country should be
preserved south african police are
investigating a deadly taxi shooting in
kozulu natal at the wiccan to understand
how the taxi mafia became so brutally
violent you need to understand where
they came from between 1948 and 1994
south africa was governed by an
all-white apartheid government
policy is one
which is called by an afrikaans word
apartheid apartheid which means our
partners in afrikaans was basically the
south african version of segregation
just more brutally enforced white people
were completely separated from non-white
people accepting that there are
differences between people they didn't
shop in the same stores live in the same
neighborhoods or use the same public
transports the two main political
parties that opposed the white national
party was called the encounter freedom
party in the african national congress
or anc these two groups were outlawed
during apartheid but they still worked
illegally to get support for the
liberation movement and inside these two
separate groups black people from
different tribes or regions of the
country like zulu zosa and bapti were
forced to work together even though they
didn't always want to which obviously
led to a lot of fighting and even more
violence
also segregated was the taxi industry
where taxis owned and operated by
non-whites was pretty much non-existent
or so the government thoughts as this
underground taxi industry grew in south
africa most drivers and associations
would eventually become affiliated with
either political parties for protection
before 1987 the taxi industry in south
africa was highly regulated and tightly
controlled you needed a permit to
operate a taxi under south african law
but permits were almost impossible to
get as a black taxi owner or driver but
that didn't stop black entrepreneurs
from operating taxis though and even
though it was illegal a lot of these
taxi drivers banded together to form
small local associations then in 1979
the first real taxi association was
started the south african black taxi
association or
sabta just a few years later a rival
association was formed called the south
african long-distance taxi association
or s-a-l-d-t-a
with more and more political pressure
being placed on the apartheid government
calls for deregulation and the illegal
taxis becoming more involved in the
anti-apartheid political parties the
government eventually decided that
trying to control the taxi industry
wasn't worth the trouble according to
them it had gotten too politicized and
that allowing black drivers into the
industry would support the economy but
as always there was a secret agenda and
the taxi industry was deregulated
overnight in 1987 and 88 a law with this
giant name deregulated the entire taxi
industry in the blink of an eye
suddenly black taxi owners can apply for
permits to transport passengers and you
can imagine what happened next anyone
with a drink to make it big and get rich
wanted to get involved in this new legal
business thousands and thousands of
people rushed to get permits and started
planning their routes the only problem
was the deregulation happened overnight
so suddenly the permit offices were
overcrowded people were waiting months
to get their paperwork approved and
eventually the only way to get your
permit was to bribe the guy who was in
charge permits were issued like confetti
and becoming a taxi driver was as simple
as buying a taxi and a gun
with so many people flooding in
competition obviously grew insanely
quickly and competition without a stable
justice system was the perfect recipe
for violence taxi wars all the while the
government stood by doing nothing and
that wasn't a coincidence that secret
agenda we talked about earlier it was
now fully in play as was typical for the
apartheid government they found a new
way to sow discord by leaving the taxi
unions to destroy each other the
security services wouldn't have to
and it worked the taxi wars that broke
out after deregulation killed many
liberation leaders and deepened the
device between the ethnic groups that
were once part of the same political
movements
for a while it looked like the national
party's plan to slow down the
revolutionary movement had worked but
then came discussions to end apartheid
and with this everyone expected the
violence to end big mistake
[Music]
between 1990 and 1994 the south african
government was in talks to formally put
an end to apartheid but instead of this
news bringing peace the violence just
got worse one of the worst taxi wars in
history was the k peninsula taxi war
which lasted from 1990 to 1992 two rival
taxi gangs the laguna taxi association
and the western cape black taxi
association went to war it started with
a shootout outside a mall in cape town
and it caused hundreds of deaths over
the next two years what was the fighting
about
permits one side had been granted
permits for a valuable route that the
other side was excluded from so they
decided to take it by force at least
that was the official story most
analysts say the wars were state
sponsored supported by the state so it
would destabilize the african
communities in the region that supported
liberation
and again it worked in 1991 an anc
member and the chair of the western cape
civic community said that he was
concerned that there were unseen forces
orchestrating and encouraging the
violence a week later the apartheid
government confiscated his gun claiming
it was illegal and three weeks after
that he was assassinated
in the words of king community leader
gladstone natamo this war is not a
political war not over route and ranks
the government has got an opportunity
with the taxi board to create a bigger
violence
and after the k peninsula taxi war the
two associations were merged to form
kota and for a minute it seemed like
there might be peace
until this agreement broke out leading
some to break out to form a new
association called kata these two taxi
associations operated mainly in
low-income areas around cape town and to
this day they are two of the most
ruthless taxi mafias in the country and
if people thought apartheid was going to
bring peace and unity to the taxi
industry once again another big mistake
[Music]
apartheid ended in 1994 and the african
national congress or anc takes control
of the government and they immediately
tried to re-regulate the taxi industry
but if they thought that was going to be
easy they had another thing coming for
them every time they tried to put new
laws in place to stabilize the industry
the taxi associations would just become
more and more violent because the taxi
unions have been left to do whatever
they wanted for the last 10 years they
have become more than just taxis they
extorted people and businesses to get
better work opportunities and sometimes
they even offer protection from other
gangs and associations to their loyal
customers the apartheid police had left
the towns and black communities to fend
for themselves and the taxi operators
were the only ones with the power and
muscle to do it so they became their own
quasi police force with so much power
they weren't just gonna let the
government tell them what to do but what
really cemented their position as taxi
mafias were the turf wars in 1990 south
africa was hit with a recession this
doubled the price of buying a taxi and
layoffs meant less people taking taxis
to work so taxi games got desperate to
control their routes so they went to war
and by the late 90s it's estimated that
more than 2 000 people died from taxi
related violence according to official
stats but that number is probably a lot
higher for taxi drivers it wasn't just a
struggle for customers it was a struggle
to survive if you couldn't meet the
daily quota your taxi owner required you
would go home empty-handed and your
family would starve with so much
competition to get the valuable routes
and transport the most customers at
least one driver was being killed every
single day it was kill or be killed and
where was the anc government in all of
this their hands were tied even they
knew the taxi industry was just too big
and powerful to take on right after
taking power
with the government standing on the
sidelines the two main taxi associations
kata and koda were in an all-out war in
cape town they had local government
officials political figures and south
african police officers all on their
payroll to exert even more power over
the people and the routes they
controlled whenever a new law-abiding
taxi association would form and be
granted legal transport routes with the
local government there would be an angry
group of drivers who would start their
own illegal taxi station to try to take
over the routes when the legal
association goes to the local government
for help the illegal taxis are fined or
impounded and then the violence starts
the illegal drivers will turn to their
mafia for help and the turf war begins
and because the local government doesn't
have enough power to stop the fighting
the legal taxi operators just end up
joining the opposing taxi association
and so the taxi wars continue people are
killed taxis are set on fire often with
their passengers still inside and the
taxi bosses are shot inside their home a
seemingly ordinary saturday night goes
horribly wrong three men approached this
house
they seen being let in by a young boy
and opened fire
killing 42 year old alien duosi in full
view of family and friends
unbeknown to the gunmen they were caught
on these cctv cameras installed at
diocese blue combo's home and if you're
a taxi driver in south africa and you're
looking for someone to take out your
competition you have a very unique
resource available to you then the
cobbies
[Music]
if you're in the market for an assassin
in south africa the person you're
looking for is a nakabi nakabi is the
zulu word for hitman and hit squads are
an essential part of any taxi
association most of the hitmen are even
employed on a retainer like you would
employ a lawyer and some are paid per
hits many of these hitmen are former
ascaris or professional assassins who
were once soldiers once you meet in the
kaabi he'll give you his price list the
cost for each person in a hit depends on
their position in the association how
many taxis they own and how well
protected they are
at 17 his first kill earned him and two
others 20 000 rand within a few years he
was earning up to a quarter of a million
rand for each hit
for a low level member you're looking at
around fifteen hundred dollars for a
boss it's eighteen thousand if you're
looking to assassinate a passenger it's
only a hundred dollars if you're looking
to assassinate a driver it's only two
hundred dollars pretty good deal if you
ask me in the eyes of a nakabi his work
is nothing more than that work like a
true hitman he has no affiliation or
loyalty his only loyalty is to the
highest bidder
how many people would you say you killed
[Music]
[Music]
is like a sport
[Music]
the taxi industry in south africa is
worth more than a billion dollars a year
in america this may not seem like much
but in south africa it's really good
money the only problem is almost none of
it goes to the actual people doing the
work the taxi drivers the 150 they earn
every month isn't even enough to cover
rent and that doesn't even include food
so in order to survive they have to
drive like maniacs to get as many
customers as possible so they can make
more money than what they owe the taxi
owner for using their vehicle every day
that's why if you try to steal customers
from another taxi to make an extra
dollar or two there's a good chance that
you will be killed
[Music]
in the 27 years after apartheid ended
the taxi associations are stronger than
ever this year riots and looting broke
out in south africa after the previous
president jacob zuma was arrested and
sent to jail for contempt of court in
the past days looting has spread from
stores to factories and warehouses
ransacking and rioting in south africa's
worst violence since apartheid
from the eastern provinces of
kwazulu-natal to johannesburg's economic
hub
highways on fire skies full of smoke
the police hopelessly outnumbered the
protest started out fueled by actual
politics but then it quickly turned into
a free-for-all shopping spree
the authorities have made nearly 2 000
arrests nationwide
but they are not in control
[Applause]
and the river horse industrial escape
police couldn't handle it alone and the
military was only deployed near the end
so the taxi drivers did their job for
them because looting and destroying
shots would mean worker layoffs empty
shots would mean no more shoppers and
both these things would leave taxis
without passengers so they blockaded the
roads to major shopping centers and
malls proving again that in many cases
taking the lot into their own hands
isn't just the taxi industry's mo it's
their only option
quote we were not trained in policing
but we are capable of defending whatever
comes our way we'll defend the business
industry in that of others if you loot
you will meet the long arm of the law
after we catch you
i have to die for defending the
community that i'm
living within it
it's fine
when i started researching this video i
had no idea any of this stuff was
happening so let me know what you guys
thought about it in the comments below
and one cool thing that i want to share
with you guys is that a ton of really
really successful entrepreneurs watch
this channel and the reason i know this
is that they reach out to me all the
time especially on instagram and i've
hung out with a few of them too and
again these are like wildly successful
entrepreneurs that made way more money
than me they built super massive
companies and brands and they all watch
the same channel that you guys are
enjoying right now so i wanted to share
that with you guys because by watching
this channel you are aligning yourself
with the right crowd speaking of
watching this channel if you're not
already click the subscribe button
because we make video essays
documentaries just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of money power war
and crime so if you enjoyed this video
you're really going to enjoy the other
ones too and speaking of reaching out to
me on instagram you can follow me on
instagram for more day in the life kind
of stuff at jtrend.io guys watching to
the end of these videos is like the
number one way to help out the youtube
algorithm so seriously thank you so much
for being part of the watchdog n club
keep sharpening that my stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you